[Music]
all right let's do it let's dive into
this Trump guy because I sense that
everything we've talked about for the
first half here a lot of your answers
now are sort of directly related to this
guy but all the weakness but not to the
personality of this guy but to the whole
system look here let me I'll take one
last that have to do it on the wider
lens then well yeah you know I imagine
somebody standing on a time line and the
center the time line is 1990 and they go
forward
25 years 2015 and maybe they go to sleep
and they wake up who are the most
important politicians of the country
when they go to sleep Bush and Clinton
who are the most important politician in
the country in 2015
Bush and Clinton what are they talking
about Iraq and health care you go back
25 years from 1990 you're in 1965 and
it's a different world there's an
afl-cio
there are riots in the cities there are
liberal Republicans and segregationist
Democrats so we have had this frozen
politics for a long time and it was
ready to be changed and Donald Trump the
existing Republican Party couldn't cope
with it and Donald Trump did he smashed
the system open so he's created some
opportunities for a new kind of
political arranged arrangement because
the old one had become so stale but what
he's also done and this is the theme of
the book is he's raising questions not
just about the way we do politics but on
the whole political system because he is
a deeply authoritarian personality his
project is authoritarian and the way he
governs is not compatible with a rule of
law society it was gonna happen one way
or another right do you think that's
fair to say or is he so unique or that
personality trait or that you know the
type of person that would be willing to
do it is so unique that he's not we have
like Trump like figures all over the
Western world you know we have a global
crisis well I mean unique to our
American system because there was no one
even though Bernie was actually talking
about rattling the system the same way
and I think that's why there was some
crossover with their audiences we have
people in I mean there's gear builders
there's marine lepen
there's the alternative for Germany we
just we're recording just a few days
before people see this program there's
an election in Italy in which the
traditional parties were swept aside and
kind of a joke party the five star
movement which was founded by a comedian
and which is you know kind of an
authoritarian populist party of the left
is now in league with a kind of neo
fascist party and we are seeing the
breakdown of the traditional parties of
the center driven by slow growth and
ethnic competition well that's what I'm
saying was it gonna happen no matter
what even if Trump had lost this
election or never rose no nothing is
going to happen no matter what people
make choices you know at the darkest
moments in American history 1932 1860
political parties and political
movements converged on programs that
were constitutional that were liberal in
the broadest sense of the term and they
found leaders who wanted to uphold the
American tradition and change it enough
that it could continue but without
violating its essence this time it's as
if he long had become President 1932 not
Franklin Delano Roosevelt okay so let's
just do like a couple minutes of Russia
so that we can get to that because I we
can't talk about Trump without talking
about Russia you you tweet a lot of
Russia obviously right about rather loud
you talk about a lot do you absolutely
believe that he himself orchestrated or
coordinated some of this stuff with the
Russian government look there remain
many secrets in the Russia story but
there's no mystery the exact modalities
of how the exchange happened that remain
uncertain but here here here is what I
think I do know and I think what you
know we know that Russia wanted Donald
Trump to be President and even more
badly wanted Hillary Clinton not to be
President we know that they intervened
in an in a massive way in an industrial
scale and we're learning more and more
all the time how big was to hurt Hillary
Clinton first the Democratic primaries
to help Donald Trump first in the
Republican primaries and then in the
general election to help Trump Clinton's
expenses can you give me just for people
that are playing total catch-up here so
what are the examples of that well let
me here's the most dramatic
the the WikiLeaks tropes are dumped in
weighs exactly timed to help Donald
Trump the Trump people were expecting
the last WikiLeaks dump of the election
sometime in the first week of October
they knew was coming they'd expected it
done about October 4th or 5th it didn't
come that day instead it was dumped on
October 7th within an hour of the Access
Hollywood tape being broken by David
Farenthold of the Washington Post the
rut the Russians or whoever controls
WikiLeaks which I believe is pretty I
believe and might compel the head of the
CIA believes this week leaked says a
cutout for the Russians have not
directly controlled by them they time
their last WikiLeaks dump to help Donald
Trump should he have a crisis in the
election and and it did and it and I in
the book I said give the
minute-by-minute tick-tock where you see
it's it's you know the Russians would
that help but dogged is the real
question whether the campaign itself was
coordinating that or look we do all
sorts of things with other with foreign
governments and elections and all kind
of stuff so whether whether the campaign
actually was coordinating it with a
foreign government which obviously would
dummy illegal we know that Donald as
opposed to them just doing it and it
having to work out for Trump to hack an
Americans email is a crime it's a big
crime if you know that a crime has been
committed against Americans by you by a
foreign government you would be annoyed
about that especially if you would
aspire to be present the United States
the idea that Donald so we don't know to
what degree yet we don't know to what
degree if any people on his campaign
work in regular back-and-forth
communication with the Russians but he
stood on a stage and in June of 2016 and
welcomed the Russians breaking American
law to steal his opponent's email to his
advantage his son took a meeting with
people who were offering him Russian
hacked information on Hillary Clinton
they didn't at the meeting the Russians
didn't deliver but you know when we say
the Russians we have to clarify between
the government and just other applets
right because everyone says the Russians
as if the lawyer one monolithic thing
the true the lawyer who was at the
meeting was somebody with intense
Kremlin connections and who
advertised that she had Kremlin
connections that she said in them in the
famous email to Don jr. the Russian
government wants to elect your father I
have information from the Russian
government it could help your campaign
and he said great I love it especially
in the summer I am telling you that if
an emissary from the Russian government
had approached george w bush in the
election of 2000 and said I have
information in Al Gore that will help
you there wouldn't have been a meeting
there were no phone call to the FBI and
and there might even have been a phone
call to the gore campaign you guys
should know about this what do you think
all right so all right so you believe
that without question there was Courtney
know so I believe the Russians helped
and I believe that Donald Trump what
it's not a belief it's on video you can
look it up no I'm from welcome to help
was ready to accept the help and profit
it from the help and that and that and I
believe it made a difference in the
election I believe also that there were
Russian attempts as far as we know
they're not successful to interfere with
the actual mechanics of voting in a
number of states what here's what I
don't know I don't know whether
information regular information flowed
back from the United States to Russia
after Don juniors meeting I don't know
that I don't know whether the Russian
operation to influence the American
election benefited from any kind of
information provided by American
counterparts those are things we don't
know what what I do know is that Donald
Trump did not act patriotically and he
did not act with respect to the American
political system and I will never get
past that do you think the Democrats
have any of the same dirt on their hands
no nothing I mean look it's not beanbag
lated many they did many things I mean
when when Hillary Clinton found that
South American beauty queen who was
offended by Donald Trump do i is it
possible the Clinton campaign paid her
money for her story that's what that's
possible but there's a difference
between there by really is a bright line
difference between the usual operations
of American politics which can be pretty
rough and accept
help from the client the clandestine
service of a foreign government give me
another example didn't make a difference
so in 2004 it was no secret that Gerhard
schröder of Germany and Jacques Chirac
the president France would dearly love
to see John Kerry beat george w bush
they made that very clear
they gave interviews they made very
clear they heard just counting the
minutes right until Bush was gone and it
was also clear in 2012 that Benjamin
Netanyahu of Israel preferred net Romney
to Obama your allies have opinions it is
ready none of those elections did we
have hostile foreign States China Russia
Iran actors like that working not
through talking to journalists but
through clandestine intelligence
services to help one candidate and hurt
another and have it all be visible and
have the candidate who has helped accept
the help and imagine if Iran had tried
to intervene in 2012 against or for
Obama or Romney and one of those
candidates had said you know Iran if
you're listening thank you for the help
right inconceivable but that's what
Trump did he did it on video it's not a
mystery so right so I want to really
talk about the presidency and sort of
the decisions in that but to sort of get
us to some sort of ending with this if
this all unfurls way I think you suspect
it will unfurl I mean I definitely would
be for impeachment right this is where
it's going so what I'm part of the part
that I'm struggling with this is if we
take all of the people that talk about
all this it seems to me what we're
talking about is okay well you you
impeach Trump and then really then we
have to do something which is
unprecedented which is most likely Pence
knew something and now you have to take
the whole administration out now we
suddenly have Paul Ryan as the president
or we have a review of the election and
then we're really at war this is not
sure just how Trump has already changed
us so no prep Heat the Russia part of
this just one of the things that have
that happened in no precedence is Lyndon
Johnson has operated a business while
president no no president in my memory
has directed his party's fun
into his own personal 80% of the money
that the Republican Party has spent on
events in last year wet was paid at a
Donald Trump branded resort so this is
like when they're holding meetings at
more loud or hidden a friend of mine
sent me this clip George Shultz to a
Secretary of State under Ronald Reagan
had been an important executive maybe
CEO at Bechtel the giant engineering
firm and at his confirmation hearing he
was asked mr. Schultz after you become
Secretary of State well your
relationship be with Bechtel and he said
well there's only one possible answer
nothing that's right that was the
standard so what you have is an attack
on every ethical norm of the US
government both financial and national
security and the and half of the country
is being borne along then the
discussions we are having our
discussions that I prompt if in 9 2013
as recently as that I said someday we'll
be having these discussions people think
well we will be so far gone even to
contemplate so that is unprocess about
are we heading toward an impatient of
crisis here's what we're heading toward
and here's what I really wanted my
deepest worries I think where there's a
good chance we're gonna arrive at this
place that Muller is going to report if
he's assuming he's not fired and he's
gonna discover a lot of things that are
violations of the law done by mid-level
and even upper level people and he may
discover some you know financial mal
practices are a lot of laws about things
like declaring you're a foreign agent
that there are technical rules about
can't campaign finance and he will
discover or may infractions of those but
the core thing in the Russian matter the
people like me are concerned about is
probably not illegal it's probably not
illegal for an American politician to
work with a hostile warrant no there
isn't such a law and it's hard to
imagine what such a law would look like
and so where we may be a year and a half
from now is confronting this that Donald
Trump worked in some way we may be I'm
not predicting this I'm just
hypothesizing worked in some way with a
hostile foreign intelligence service but
he himself broke no law in doing that
and now the country is going to have to
process
how to deal with that and it's going to
be part of what is going on in this new
era which is ripping apart the but the
the cords that bind us because one of
the things that makes a country is the
assumption how your connections to your
fellow Americans however much you may
disagree with them and however you may
he may have a different color skin or
have a different accent from you that
bond is more powerful than the bonds
outside the border and as American
politics becomes emphasized I think a
lot of people are saying my connections
with this global movement of reactionary
populist forces are more powerful than
my bonds to fellow Americans of
different skin and different accent and
because of that unless you could show me
that Donald Trump literally broke a
federal criminal statute I don't mind
what he did so how do we get out of this
how do we get out of either that
inevitability or do we just end up
literally fighting on the streets the
way we get out of it is we have to the
new American nation up and so we have to
do if we get out of this we're gonna do
something some are going to sound pretty
liberal and some are going to sound
pretty conservative I believe we need a
lot less immigration because that's you
have to we have to make a nation again
we've taken on a lot of new people and
I'm a naturalized citizen myself I grew
up in Canada and my family's from
Eastern Europe making nations is hard
and time-consuming so that's the
conservative part of the part you need
Allah said that that sounds pretty
trumpian actually you have a you'll have
the whole left and ever virtually every
Democrat against the other okay you need
a thicker social insurance network you
need you need a real health care system
because what we have to deal with we
have to deal with the crisis and life
expect we have to care for each other
more the idea that we went through in
the whole second Obama term people who
didn't graduate from college living less
long than their parents which literally
did not happen in the great depression
and not only did nobody do anything but
no one even noticed maybe this was found
out my pair of economists
I happened to look at some data there's
no one was paying a lot of attention to
this the opioid epidemic erupted with no
one in Washington paying much attention
to it
we need we're going to need to build a
stronger a stronger sense of national
identity and but it's going to be a
different kind of national again he's
not going to be Sarah Palin's America
but we have to we're gonna have to find
some way of agreeing what it means to be
an America and what it means not to be
an American but it is the inherent
problem there that were caught now
between Trump and sort of the Democrats
that love identity politics and neither
one of those is giving us the answer to
that I mean where is the voice that's
where is the political voice that's
learning exactly what you just said look
we've been here before you know that
melting pot story that you were told it
wasn't true at the time it was a myth we
created later when the United States
entered World War one the biggest
minority in the country was one of the
biggest with german-speaking Americans
and there was real doubt about what the
United States would be able to fight
Germany in the first world war because
the German Americans might be disloyal
and the country went on a ramp having to
ban German language in newspapers it
suppressed German language schools it
wasn't a melting pot it was a harsh and
rancorous process and the United States
had in the 1988 aftermath of World War
one um pogroms in American cities that
were very you know by white Americans
against blacks that were deadlier than
the anti-semitic could programs that
took place under the Tsar those were
facts of our history and out of that we
built but in the years after World War
two and for half a century after it's
been a strong sense of national identity
we have to do that state building and
nation building process again and some
and it's going to not look is going to
look out partly liberal partly
conservative but it's going to be a new
politics for a new century and and the
idea that people are going to that and
if anyone is standing around saying I
don't know I think what I prefer the
problems of 1982 so I can have the
solutions of 1982 I mean say you just
not helping what would you say to the
people that would say and this is a
little bit more where I fall on all this
that the government
is just not the answer to any of these
things that I hear you on all of these
problems without question no doubt but
that to me at this point that everything
you're talking about is showing me the
government no longer functions at the
federal government specifically no
longer functions in a way that it can
cope or deal with any of these things we
get then bad actors that want to wreck
the whole thing or we get these
mid-level management people that never
really do anything and that you could
look at virtually every member of
Congress that all the answers that
you're asking for I would argue have
almost nothing to do with the government
and that there's other ways now
especially because of the internet and
everything else there's other ways that
we can connect and build things right
now Elan musk is the guy that's getting
us into space Warren Buffett's working
on an alternate health care plan you
know like that
there's just other ways to do this and
that those machines they can't work
anymore
look something a lot of great social
transformations have in the American
history is different from that of other
countries in this way that oftentimes
the way the countries address part the
most effective cultural change in my
lifetime was probably was Mothers
Against Drunk Driving
that changed Americans attitudes they
changed laws too I mean the government
state has a role III think that for
things like the gun debate I mean that I
think that is going to be ultimately
addressed if it is addressed not by
state action but by private action which
is whatever the laws are just if you if
you have kids and you care about them
don't have a gun in the house you know
that just as Mothers Against Drunk
Driving changed the idea that it was
funny drunk driving was funny to the
idea that was not funny
so we have to change idea that if you're
a responsible parent your arm to a new
better understanding that if you're
armed you're not a responsible parent
but the Conservatives won't be happier
won't say that that's right that's right
don't want won't be but it just happens
to be saying the facts don't care about
your feelings it's just a fact I think
Ben would argue with that fact but maybe
you can do that some but we get reminds
me has a sensitive feelings yeah but
they're of course the government has to
do this and it's true that dollar for
dollar and pound for pound
the American government has always been
less effective than other governments
but sometimes it's more effective and
sometimes it's less effective there are
things that the government is going to
have to do and the government doesn't
have to administer the health care
system I would hope it wouldn't uh
there's a role for the profit motive and
for competition but the idea that we are
going to accept a country in which large
numbers of Americans are uncovered in or
outside the healthcare system and that
people literally die because they get
they can't afford dental care and their
teeth fester and the festering gets into
their body and it kills them that has to
change I mean that in part that the role
of the state is part of if we're going
to have a new ethic of nationhood with a
higher border and more mutual care yeah
of course government's going to be part
of that and by the way not that only the
federal government because a lot of the
I mean the country is big I mean running
California's challenge enough so since
you don't say you're a conservative
specifically anymore I mean what if
people are listening and going I get
this it's a little bit of book because
there's a lot of big government here
there's I know you're saying you would
prefer the government not have to do
health insurance all that you're you're
sort of all over the place right now
which i think a lot of people are I
think that's the situation we're in
right now what do you call that now not
that and I only ask about labels because
although they're becoming increasingly
meaningless I think it helps people go
alright this is my starting point well I
don't have a label for it because I
think this is one of those moments in
American history where you have to do
something new you know for 25 years
after the Civil War Americans kept
arguing both about the Civil War and
about its financial consequences and
then they began to notice that in the
aftermath that they had these big cities
grow up that were intensely corruptly
governed and a new new movements came
along that said we have you know it's
not like the legacy of the civil wars is
resolved it's still not fully resolved
but in the meantime we have to figure
how do we get streetcars in New York how
do we get the water clean how do we make
sure the aldermen are on to aren't all
taking bribes and that new political and
at first they weren't they just knew
what the problems were and
they worked on the problems they
developed labels to describe what they
were doing but first you start I think
one of the ways that especially on the
right
warm looking one of the ways that we go
wrong is a new problem is presented to
us and instead of looking at the problem
studying it we reach for volume of the
Talmud and we say what did Rabbi Russell
Kirk say about this three-quarters of a
century ago
well he never talked about it therefore
we can't do anything about it
I feel good about this I feel like
you've presented a couple of interesting
ideas that I thank you that I haven't
quite talked about here and you're
coming at it from from different angles
is there anyone that's doing this
politically I mean who are the people
that you right now think are making
we're doing it right now
you know and I know I think look there
there are a lot of things that come out
of the Trump era that I are actually
good their perverse gifts that he's
given us one of them is by lying all the
time he's helped us understand how
important it is that people tell the
truth
I mean one of the you know you're
concerning what goes on in campus you
know that the phrase post truth began as
a compliment not a criticism it began by
by people who wanted to overthrow
totalitarian truth structures and open
the way to many multiple truths and they
discovered that when you do that in
politics what you don't get the opposite
of truth isn't truth the opposite of
truth is lying we've seen rising levels
of civic engagement and we I think are
seeing especially among the on a sense
that the political categories they've
inherited are obsolete yeah and that
they have to start looking at problems
anew and that they have to begin with
the problems and then develop the
solutions and then people will disagree
whether the new party system will come
from is you know as we really
contemplate how do we improve the health
outcomes of our fellow citizens how do
we deal with drugs how do we deal with
the declining life expectancy of those
who don't go to college they're going to
disagree and then they'll find
like-minded groups and they'll end up
inside the Republican and Democratic
Party so institutions will always be
there the content will change and along
the way we'll find new names yeah but
anyone politically I think I appreciate
the compliment and I think there are
some people that are trying to make some
sense these days but really I mean do
you think anyone politically I think it
will start at the state level you know I
think the mayor here in Los Angeles
example someone who's trying to figure
out how things work Andrew Cuomo in New
York I'm in kind of a bully but cares
about why doesn't why does it cost three
times as much or whatever it is to build
a subway in New York as in London and so
I think this the regeneration of the
American political system has always
come from cities and states and I think
that will be even more true in the 21st
century I mean here in California what
you need you need a revival of political
competition mm-hmm
one of the reasons why I stay a
registered Republican is you know I look
at California said this is what happens
when you get a one-party state you get
factional politics it doesn't mitigate
the problems of ethnically Griffin
politics it makes them worse
so we're gonna need we're gonna need to
party competition we're gonna need new
solutions on it that's what that's what
I try to do in my work is to try to
offer you know the possibility of a more
useful kind of politics yeah it's
interesting because I mean that's
exactly what I try to do with the show
and even last week I had Mike
Shellenberger on who's running as a
Democrat you know he he's more of an
old-school Democrat and he's into
nuclear power and all sorts of new ideas
and using technology to solve our
problems
Ronnie against Gavin Newsom who is who's
the hero of the left and he thinks
sounds too left and then this week I
have you on to discuss your frustrations
with the Conservatives and all that so
that's this is what we have to keep
doing at the end of the day that's all
we got right that's all as well as and
as long and we have to defend our
ability to do that and defend that both
against those who would use violence and
against those who use corruption to try
to shut down proper discussions perfect
that's a perfect ending right there
thank you fo Isis my pleasure I suspect
we'll do this again maybe we'll get
banned in here and we'll do that little
facts over feelings things that we get a
couple other people in here to to mix up
some of those ideas for more on David
follow him on twitter at david fromm and
check out his book from Bhakra see in
the link right down below
[Music]
you